hey everyone welcome back to the cosmic
wonder I'm Warren Thompson and today we
have some new developments in the case
of Jonathan Majors recently things were
looking pretty good with Jonathan majors
and his case where he is being tried for
several cases of assault against his
ex-girlfriend Grace Jabari Jonathan
Majors was arrested for allegedly
assaulting her but recently in a report
from newsweek.com we found out that
Priya Chaudhry Jonathan Majors lawyer
and Majors himself provided the NYPD
with enough evidence along with the NYPD
conducting their own investigation the
NYPD found probable cause to arrest
Grace Jabari the person who is the
alleged victim into Jonathan Major's
assault case but Jonathan majors has now
claimed that she assaulted him and this
was the evidence they provided and the
evidence that the NYPD found to find
probable cause to arrest her and Majors
his lawyer chadrace said this and I
quote within hours of viewing the
evidence and conducting their own
thorough investigation the NYPD found
probable cause to arrest Grace Jabari
for salting John Jonathan Majors
considering this development we extend
our gratitude to the nyp detectives for
their efforts however we have recently
found out this morning from a report
from Business Insider that Manhattan
prosecutors were reluctant to press
charges against Jabari and the Chinatown
police station issued her with an
incident card and not issuing the arrest
warrant and the incident card which
basically means that she is called into
the police office for questioning was
then revoked as well basically the NYPD
Chinatown Precinct changed their mind
according to this report from Business
Insider and they decided to not arrest
Grace Jabari so they had the intent to
arrest her but then cancel that then
they gave her the incident card but
canceled that as well and according to a
report from the NYPD to Newsweek they
stated regarding the incident that
occurred on March 25th of 2023 the
investigation is ongoing there are no
additional arrests at this time
basically state that despite what Priya
chaudrey Jonathan Major's lawyer and
their team presented them with and
despite what they said originally when
presented with this evidence they are
not going through with the arrest so
things were looking pretty good for
Jonathan Majors until the NYPD revoked
their decision and now last night
Rolling Stone released a huge article
about Jonathan majors and how he has
been known over the past decade for
extreme abuse Rolling Stone states that
they have done a three-month
investigation talking to many of his
past co-workers and schoolmates speaking
with over 40 people who have known
Jonathan majors and now rollingstone.com
has come out with the article basically
stating everything that they have
learned about Jonathan majors and what
people have said about him with the
article titled Jonathan Majors extreme
abuse allegedly goes back nearly a
decade so we'll break down this article
talk about what it means for his case
and talk about what it means for
Jonathan Major's role as king the
Conqueror in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe the subtitle for this article
reads made was abusive with his Partners
aggressive on sets and a source of
toxicity at Yale two dozen sources tell
Rolling Stone Majors vehemently denies
all accusations Rolling Stone goes on in
the article to say during this
three-month investigation Rolling Stone
spoke with more than 40 people who have
known Majors during his time in graduate
school his Hollywood career and his
romantic relationships many describe
Majors as being a complicated
unpredictable and sometimes violent man
who can switch from Charming to cold in
a Flash and they do state here that all
of the sources for this article request
to remain anonymous citing fear of
career repercussions and personal
retribution from Majors some claim they
were prohibited from speaking and
rolling stone quotes here my only
response can be that I am silenced by an
NDA he had me sign says one person who
worked with Majors so all of their
sources and statements that they are
getting from these Witnesses are going
to remain anonymous and the article is
very long and pretty repetitive but I'll
give you the main details that they have
found out with speaking with all of
these different Witnesses Rolling Stone
States throughout conversations with
more than a dozen sources Rolling Stone
has learned of two women Majors
allegedly abused either physically and
or emotionally now again this is
allegedly so this is not proven and in
parentheses it states that two women
declined to comment for this article
with one of the woman through a
spokesperson citing fear of Retribution
they continue on to State one woman who
dated Majors was strangled and
physically and emotionally abused nine
sources familiar with their relationship
claim at first the sources say Majors
was romantic with the woman before
becoming more manipulative and volatile
the situation became really extreme
abuse physical and mentally One Source
claims and allegedly escalated to the
point of him strangling her two sources
claim she tried to leave multiple times
and had an exit plan at one point but
remained in the relationship Majors
emotionally abused a second woman he was
dating nine people familiar with their
relationship ship allege the woman said
her relationship with Majors was
emotional torture according to One
Source though the woman told friends at
the time Mages was never physically
abusive with her she said there were
moments of near violence where he would
get filled with rage says the source of
woman confided in the woman told the
source that Majors would say he needed
to hit something or punch a wall or
something of that nature and here's
where it actually gets kind of
convoluted Rolling Stone basically cites
that they can't confirm anything with
these actual two women who were
allegedly abused physically and
emotionally they even State as part of
Major's legal team's response to Rolling
Stone's request for comment on the abuse
allegations his attorneys sent six
character witness statements from women
who Majors had dated or was close with
Major's attorney noted in his statement
that Rolling Stone was provided
statements from Mr Majors actual past
romantic Partners attesting to his
character in The falsity of the charges
but Rolling Stone purposefully ignored
those facts and red flags and published
the false charges anyways but then
Rolling Stone states that in fact
Rolling Stone reached out to all six
people three say they never gave
majors's team permission to release such
statements another woman declined to
share the statement credited to her by
majors's team saying it was pre-written
not truthful that she had never approved
of its release which is really really
odd for a law firm to do they typically
would not do that unless they did
actually have consent to send those
statements in so that's a really
interesting mix up here however they do
state that one woman did consent to
making her statement public it is Haley
Carter a woman who Majors dated from age
13 to 18 describe Majors as sweet kind
and gentle in a message drafted in late
March after 20 years of knowing him I
can tell you who Jonathan is he did not
do these things he is exactly the
opposite of what these allegations say
Jonathan is the most self-controlled
disciplined well-mannered person I know
we all call him the Peacekeeper he is
not violent in any way now the article
also says it speaks with people that
have worked with Jonathan May majors in
his acting career or people that were
his co-students at Yale and they all say
that he was really hard to work with and
be around however here is what Jonathan
Major's team had to say in response to
all of these allegations they State
Jonathan Majors vehemently denies
Rolling Stones as false allegations that
he physically verbally or emotionally
abused anyone let alone any of his past
romantic Partners these allegations are
based entirely on hearsay because
neither of the Romantic Partners
referenced were willing to engage with
rolling stone for the article
demonstrating their outright falsity and
this is coming from Jonathan Major's
attorney Dustin a push who also stated
that Jonathan Majors also denies any
allegations of abuse violence or
intimidation during his time at Yale the
allegations that Mr Majors got physical
with or physically intimidated anyone on
any movie Set are downright false
everyone who has worked with Mr Majors
knows that he employs an immersive
method acting style and while that can
be misconstrued as rudeness at times
those who know Mr majors and work in the
industry have attested to his dedication
to his craft as well as his kindness and
that is pretty much the basis of the
article Rolling Stone States Anonymous
sources have said that Jonathan Majors
is very intimidating very pushy very
hard to work with and that a couple of
relationships he was in he was
emotionally abusive and in one
physically abusive but these two women
would not speak to Rolling Stone and it
doesn't seem like anybody from any of
the recent movies that he's worked on is
willing to come out and state anything
about the case either so right now this
is all hearsay and more importantly this
won't actually affect his legal case now
it could still affect his standing with
Marvel Studios but we'll talk about that
in just a bit as far as the case is
concerned against his alleged abuse
against Grace jibari there isn't too
much that can be used here in court yes
they can present Anonymous sources but
what they would really need is the two
previous girlfriends to go to court and
testify and even then that is for a
completely unrelated case what he is in
trial for right now is the several cases
of assault against Grace Jabari
specifically and based off of the
details that we have learned over the
past couple of months Jonathan majors
and his team seemingly have substantial
evidence to prove that he is innocent
they claim and some footage has even
been released publicly showing Grace
Jabari after the alleged assault right
after the alleged assault at a nightclub
appearing to be perfectly fine she
claimed that Majors broke her hand broke
a finger on her hand and lacerated her
ear and in the footage we can see that
her hand is perfectly fine and that her
ear is also perfectly fine as well and
majors's team claims that they have much
more evidence including CCTV footage
which was used to get Grace Jabari
arrested for assault against Majors
himself and they have many eyewitnesses
that are willing to testify a Major's
behalf including the driver who was
driving Jabari and Majors when the
supposed assault took place so I'm
obviously not a lawyer but I'm not sure
any of this is really going to affect
case right now now the women could come
out and state that these allegations are
true and they were abused and they could
press charges against majors at that
time or take him to court but I don't
think this will affect his case that
much however it could affect his
standing with Marvel Studios even if he
ends up being innocent sometimes the
studios take these things into account
however at this point in time Marvel
Studios has worked with Jonathan Majors
during Loki season 1 and of course
during Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania
so they can make their own judgments
they have combined over a year working
physically in the presence with Jonathan
Majors so if these allegations are true
and Marvel Studios agrees that he is
actually quite difficult to work with
and even if he is proven innocent in his
current court case they could decide to
let him go and recast King however if
he's proven innocent and they like
working with him and they don't think
that these allegations are true then
they can keep him on his King again we
try to be pretty unbiased when talking
about this case and if these allegations
are true of course it is is extremely
sad and if they aren't true it's also
extremely sad that somebody is trying to
end his career but basically right now
we are waiting till the next court date
for this which is very early August to
see what evidence majors and his team
presents to the court and what the
Court's decision is going to be but of
course if we hear anything else on the
updates of this case we'll be sure to
let you know so hit the Subscribe button
and hit that notification Bell so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
videos also today is the last day to
enter our monthly giveaway for a chance
to win an Xbox series X A PS5 some
Marvel Legends items or some DC items we
pick a winner at the end of each month
and the winner gets to pick one item
only one day left you can also follow us
on patreon our website and join our
Discord server and of course Instagram
and Twitter as always thank you all so
much for watching wolf wolf
baby